Come on Otto.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
Come on Otto.
You’re doing great.
Let's go.
Time out!
Have you seen the score?
I’m not getting a single shot on.
You got to think positive!
11-0, game to Emil!
Well Otto, at least we had fun.
I didn't have any fun.
Have you,
have you seen my banana?
No.
I can't find it anywhere.
Are you sure it's not here?
I'm sure I had a banana with me.
I actually saw that you had one earlier.
- Yeah exactly.
Well done guys.
Footwork for 3 minutes.
And start!
What’s that popping sound?
Aaaand change!
On second thought,
one more minute.
Miikka I think your spin needs a bit more pop.
Oh yeah, thank you.
Like that!
Five minutes ago,
I was getting everything on the table.
Okay Coach, look at this.
Don't miss this.
Yeah, I never miss your shots.
Coach?
Sometimes you have bad days.
You missed it again!
What?
Everything is going pretty well here.
It's pretty good yeah.
What did you say?
Did you see that?
Keep playing keep playing!
Yeah Miikka,
go play with the other players.
Otto is too good for you.
Player O’Connor,
chin up, look to the sky!
Player two!
That's good.
New guy,
excellent!
Now we can start table tennis.
Left, right, left, right,
left, right, left, right, left, right.
What is this?
Let's crawl!
Perform!
New guy, perfect!
Okay this is ridiculous.
I'm out of here.
Continue!
When are we going to play?
I have no idea.
Today's main exercise.
Over!
Under!
Backhand!
Forehand!
Take cover!
Good!
Otto take cover.
Back to the line guys!
Come back!
No, no.
You need to hit the last shot here.
But I won it.
Harder!
I said harder.
Okay.
Come on.
I'll give you a hard one.
Too slow.
Too high.
Oh, come on Miikka.
Faster movement with your hand.
Stop fooling around.
All right, guys.
Next excersise.
Starts off,
with a short serve.
Short receive, long push,
diving shot!
Instead of normal block,
you do one with that.
The footwork has to be a flowing motion.
Spin it up. Loads of spin.
And up to here.
Cross down the line. Cross.
And then short ball. Long ball.
And down the line again.
Backhand block.
Forehand, loop, counterattack.
Fake shot over there.
And then we come in with a serve.
Chop block,
receive your own chop block.
Receive one more.
You do a cartwheel..
Come on!
Move move!
Yes, that's right.
It’s looking good Otto!
Keep going keep going!
What do you want?
Are you sure
you want to come to the table?
That was, that was impressive.
Okay guys, good session.
Let's pick up all the balls
and finish off.
Okay I think that's everything.
Everything?
What is this?
Maybe there was one or two balls.
What are these?
I have no idea how they got there.
I just checked it and there was nothing.
This one was in the forest!
I can't believe you didn't check it.
Why would we check the forest?
In the forest?
Emil!
This was in your bag!
You missed one over here Otto.
Okay that has to be the last one.
Did you check the flying ball?
Flying balls?!
Yeah you got to check the flying balls!
What?!
It’s going well.
Can you give me some space?
And then chin up. Chin up.
Lift this leg.
Why?
And then lower, lower, lower.
Yeah.
Like this yeah.
I got it. I got it. I got it.
No, no, no.
Fast!
And then you get the spin!
You know the combo we practised.
Whenever you get the chance.
Let's go.
Come on!
The coach who slightly over reacts
Yes. Good.
Let's go. Let's go!
coach.
Seven-six
Go back to your seat
Ridiculous.
Absolutely.
Please sit down.
I'm behaving.
Emil,
Remember the
Short serve
That's enough for today.
Oh, come on Miikka.
Let's just finish off these balls.
Just these balls...
There are still a few left.
The coach who has unlimited balls
Okay there was still a few more.
How many?
How many balls do you have?
That's a few left!
Come on!
Keep on!
These are the last ones.
Come on!
Good Miikka
Those were the last ones
Or actually...
And if you haven't heard,
we're going to make the world's
largest
table tennis racket
made completely out of chocolate.
If we reach 5 million subscribers
by the end of the year,
make sure to subscribe
so we can make this happen.
This one is tough
Oh, this one was wet.
Do a cartwheel
Yeah yeah
Keep going
Why are you laughing?
That's enough.
Well done, guys.
Just like my meatballs.